amico mio sei di nuovo nella nella parte
di youtube quella dove vedi youtubers
giocare con una fetta di pane ogni tanto
fermati pop fermi fermati pensa cosa ne
stai facendo della tua vita
metti like al video mentre ci pensa poi
continua a pensarci intanto io gioco a
sta roba
però tu pensi che non si sa mai bella
tutti ragazzi infatti a questo nuovo
video sono falli genio design brad è un
gioco che ho fatto un po di volte però
l'ultima volta che l'ho rifatto ho
provato la modalità storia che non lo
facevo da una vita
mi duole riconoscere che ci sono delle
parti che non ho non ho completato tipo
il giardino che disdetta proprio per il
mio canale non averlo fatto
allora proviamo a fare innanzitutto
l'ultima volta che avevo ci ho giocato
ho fatto fino al bagno
quindi direi di fare il garage se riesco
anche giardino ma quelle per giocatori
veramente forti comunque il gioco in
questione si chiama a sé brad per chi
non lo conoscesse siete fuori dal mondo
e forse è meglio ve lo siate è la dura
vita di un pezzo di pane quale sono io
adesso è difficile perché se tocco terra
mi sporco e se mi sporco il tosto non è
più commestibile ma se il tosta su i
cestini allora e commestibili ma anzi io
inzuppo sempre il mio pane successi
dell'immondizia
dicono che fa bene trovato in ogni
livello devo trovare il modo giusto di
tostare il mio toste perché ogni livello
è diverso come potrei tostarlo qua visto
che negli altri deve saltare su un
televisore rotto fare cose del genere
qua penso che tu debba stare sulla luce
o devi far saltare qualcosa laggiù non
lo so comunque devo raggiungere quella
parte li vedo roba elettronica devono
capire come tostare il mio non è facile
era che non è facile sto gioco non lo
direste mai
dopo la parte di modo easy tipo magari
innanzi tutto perfetto curvando fritschi
wan ifra l adda bellissimo intanto io e
usando gesti che non so io non giorno
gioco maicon colore xbox non sui tasti
veloce cosa fai
non ho toccato per terra incredibile vi
starete sicuramente chiedendo come fai
ad attaccarti alle
gesù esiste e mi vede mentre mi
appiccico alle scatole toccato per una
più per terra l'altro non posso stare
attaccato per più di un tot perché perdo
aderenza è veramente giuro sto iniziando
con un livello un po più avanzato in
realtà quindi è normale io faccia schifo
ma vi assicuro che questo gioco fa fa
schifo chiunque perché veramente
difficile
mi ricordo ragazzi che appena uscito ha
fatto uno scalpore incredibile perché
dopo got simulator era il gioco meno
intelligente sul pianeta anche go
simulator faceva il suo porca di una
vacca morta a posto a posto sto metallo
è perfetto per condire i pani quindi la
commessi vita cosciente prolina sì molto
bene tutto bene molto bene devo stare
attento a non buttar giù le scatole
perché vuole il problema
potrei anche decidere di andare da
un'altra parte tipo di sopra per come ci
vado lì sopra o faccio un salto fatto
veramente bene
ci provo vai
sì va bene va bene veloce veloce di
salire sopra con qualche modo non so
come perfetto io con questa roba ci
abbiamo portato il letame come fa essere
commestibile
amen ce l'ho fatta dopo un'ora e mezza
difficilissimo ai loft host va bene
ragazzi sta parte sta per essere
completata da un maestro dei videogiochi
quale sono se magari non si aprisse il
frigo in questo momento sarebbe ancora
più easy e sempre molti mi chiedono ma
scusami ma tutti gli studi per farlo
youtuber no ma ti assicuro che con la
tua laurea questo non lo fai te lo
assicuro
staccati non cadere giù pero per
cortesia non cadere giù no perché un per
cento dai solo l'un per cento ragazzi un
per cento va bene per cento per non ci
credo mi è rimasta la commestibilità un
per cento cioè se tocco una formica sono
morto
dovrei accendere questa roba qua sotto e
se mi butto sopra dovrei toast armi si
spera non cadere adesso ti prego non è
vero la considero vinta ragazzi siamo su
giardino giardino sarebbe livello dopo
perché questa roba qua che ho fallito
nel fare adesso ce l'avevo fatta una
volta quindi ero arrivato a giardino
giardino e non l'ho mai finito credo
perché non c'è quella dopo
non ho mai sbloccata allora per testare
stavolta mi sa che devo andare nel
motore della macchina non ne sono sicuro
ma credo che se io vado di là perfetto
perfetto molto bene molto bene molto
bene
se continuiamo così però l'aderenza vi
finisce quindi o ti muovi o ti muovi
cava capisce che gli fa gli speed and
running sta roba sulla pianta sono salvo
mamma mia che mira che mira ma se ci
riprovo un milione di volte giuro non ci
riesco non so come ho fatto
c'è tra me e me dice vabbè si è lì la
pianta è lì ma non ce la farò mai
arrivarci ce l'ho fatta assurdo
va bene basta che non tocco terra la
terra stessa va bene la terra quella per
terra no neanche questa quanto vedo
veloce che vai
veloce di risalire velocissimo perché
non ho aderenza perfetto perfetto
perfetto perfetto a salire sono un
fenomeno andare in giro invece facciamo
schifo by così perfetto va bene pane
chiodi chissenefrega
vai avanti che schifo cos'è quella del
ruggine bike e la ruggine buona madonna
ragazzi sto facendo per no no la piatta
il verde ci salva la vita
madonna la pianta ma salvato il deretano
in una maniera che non avete idea ce
l'avete perché avete visto vabbè non fa
niente basta che ci arrivi ok bearing cm
6 ore ma va bene va bene chi se ne frega
vai avanti ragazzi sono in tutto che gli
è successo ma che è successo in un
minuto ho fatto sta roba come guardalo
lì che genio incredibile
va bene ci sono i mattoni luciano
griglia la come faccio da toast armi
secondo me devo entrare nella macchina
perché non mi fa strano che io debba
andare sulla griglia mi sembra troppo
semplice proviamo tanto stato bravo dai
pro grande aree sulla griglia
ok ok aderenza a posto a posto amico mio
la macchina a posto
red la targa c'è scritto pane in inglese
ora perché la griglia non è attaccata
niente quindi non funziona e un bait
cioè nel senso è un esca e per fatti
andarli a morire quindi non serve ad ora
andiamo avanti
i ragazzi di oggi no e l'acqua non ha
detto che no no ragazzini di oggi che
giocano a fort night non capiranno mai
cosa vuol dire il vero progaming presumo
che io debba farsi devo accendere la
macchina come come come la accendo la ma
come si entra nel cielo sportello aperto
come entrò nella marca in chiusa ci
siamo sportello per te non è chiuso lo
spot come faccio potrei entrare al tetto
si butta un mattone ma il mattone dic
arriva lì ok che vedevi entrare per
favore bene non toccare per terra che
schifo ma dopo 33 per cento
il sedile va bene per terra nova al
sedile vabbè dai ragazzi non sono fatto
per questo la mia vita da youtube è
troppo breve
ci provo l'ultima volta sono gesu no che
no non è vero ma sta registrando questo
schifo via via via via via via via via
via voglio morire morire devi morire e
morì c'è il tasto da fatemi ridare i
soldi voglio i soldi grazie ragazzi
spero che questo video vi sia piaciuto
questa è in breve il più grande gioco
esistente su steam
ve lo consiglio soprattutto quando
volete fare qualcosa può giocare
qualcosa di calmo no ai brand ragazzi
spero che vi sia piaciuto come al solito
servizio bisogna solo un bel haj anche
un commento mi piace anche alla pagina
di instagram con i video delle scritte
se non siete ancora i siti iscrivetevi e
noi ci vediamo ad una prossima atto
stata di pane o cosa del genere bella
ragazzi
[Musica]